we all know things on euphoria can get a
little bit crazy
and that's why we can't stop watching
but things were also insane
behind the scenes one scene required the
construction of a rotating room and
another had actress zendaya reaching for
her inhaler
how would i rate you that's not the
point
of course we're excited about the second
season of euphoria
we just want to make sure our favorites
are going to be returning to the cast
thankfully we've confirmed zendaya will
be back to reprise her role as rue
bennett and the cast has gotten together
for table reads for the new scripts
this pic confirmed angus cloud will be
back and sydney sweeney announced her
return on the chicks in the office
podcast
storm reed claims that she'll be back to
reprise her role as gia
and we'd be surprised if the rest of the
main cast doesn't return for the second
season
right in the first episode of euphoria
things got spun out of control
and pulling off this tricky scene took a
lot more than building a simple set
piece
the crew actually constructed a rotating
room that zendaya walked through with
cameras following her the whole way
according to zendaya it was incredibly
disorienting
but she had it better than the
partygoers who had to be strapped
to the room while it was rotating
everything is just spinning
and you have no sense of where the real
world
is putting together a musical number may
sound simpler than having a room rotate
but the all for us scene in episode 8
was totally over the top
it took over 200 people including a
choir and marching band
and there were snare bass and tenor
drums a woodwind section
and brass instruments in play although
it was a ton of work and required
careful coordination from the
choreographer zendaya claims the energy
on set was high
and everyone was excited about the scene
and happy to be on the euphoria set
a lot of hard work went into making the
first season and the cast is already
talking about what will happen next
according to storm reed the cast knows
that we're excited about the follow-up
to the first season and all of our
questions will soon be answered
during an interview with entertainment
weekly storm confirmed that any
lingering questions will be answered in
the first couple of episodes in the
second season
while that's definitely exciting we also
assume that those episodes will also
cause us to ask
new and exciting questions about our
favorite characters
euphoria creator sam levinson believes
the right camera angles can help express
the character's emotions
so instead of filming in a static set he
makes ample use of glide cameras and
dollies to follow the stars while they
move through each scene
sam believes that this ends up making
the show feel more personal to those of
us watching at home
how do we allow our camera to articulate
it for the character
we're excited to see our favorite
euphoria characters returning for a
second season
but we're also optimistic about who
we'll be meeting next
actor kelvin harrison jr has been in
films like loose and waves
and now he's joining the cast of
euphoria apparently
kelvin wanted to be part of the first
season but could not make it work with
his busy schedule
but now he's looking forward to getting
started and says he's already enjoying
his connections to the rest of the cast
a casting call for the second season
revealed that they were looking for
someone to play darien who's an outsider
described as sensitive
vulnerable and mischievous who might not
be the coolest guy around but is one of
the more interesting ones
could this be kevin's role on the show
finding a carnival to film episode 4 was
a tough task
so the crew ended up making their own
they brought in all of the carnival
rides and equipment just two days before
the scene was filmed
obviously the crew had their work cut
out for them but the cast struggled with
this scene too
zendaya called it a nightmare and said
it was so dusty she was forced to rely
on her inhaler
sam levinson admitted that it was both
dusty and freezing cold
and it took six long days to get all of
the shots they needed to make the
episode
even though it was hard work both
zendaya and sam agreed that it was worth
it in the end
sam had the idea to create a setting
that can be
dreamy but based in reality
barbie ferreira opened up to the new
york times about her thoughts on her
character cat hernandez
she says that she's looking forward to
cat making bad decisions in season 2
and that she thinks her character is a
part of the lgbt plus community
some fans believe that barbie was
hinting cat's orientation will be a plot
point in the second season
and could influence her storyline
coming up with a script for euphoria was
not easy and neither was getting the
music
just right creator sam levinson believes
in thinking outside the box and
combining many different styles to get
the show's soundtrack
just right he described the music for
euphoria as danny elfman meets jesus
meets gospel
and that's actually the perfect
description composer labyrinth
totally understood sam's vision and made
it his mission to combine auditory and
visual effects to get the biggest impact
possible in each scene
the cast members of euphoria do a lot
more than just reading lines
they have a certain amount of input on
their characters hunter schaefer plays
jules vaughn and says she feels an
intense connection to her character
she admits that at first it was a little
awkward since transition is such a
personal experience but
she was glad to be able to portray
aspects of it that many people may not
think about
it was also a challenge to relive some
of her own memories and experiences that
were painful at the time
but overall hunter loves being a part of
the show and the fact that jules is
based on her
i don't want to have this conversation
when he was getting ready to put the
show together sam levinson made vision
boards for the characters
and actually used a photo of zendaya as
the one for roo
zandaya was flattered that sam thought
she was qualified to bring the character
to life
and is extremely proud of her work on
the series sydney sweeney likes making
interactive diaries for her characters
and yes
she has one of cassie howard but as for
how it looks like that's going to stay a
secret since sydney avoids sharing them
with even her fellow cast members
the stars of euphoria claim it's a fun
show to work on but they have to deal
with a lot of heavy themes that
can be draining according to sidney
sweeney the cast has access to an
intimacy coordinator behind the scenes
who makes sure everyone feels
comfortable during the filming process
sydney claims the coordinator helps them
speak up and works to make sure the
environment on set feels safe
for everyone euphoria has such a
talented cast that you might be
surprised by how many of them are new to
acting
barbie ferreira was nervous the casting
director wouldn't take her seriously
because of her past as a model
she worried that seeing her in person
without perfect hair and lighting would
mean missing out on the part
and says that she's grateful for
euphoria for giving her a chance to
prove herself
how she wants to be portrayed how she
wants to be viewed in the world
hunter schaefer was working as a
full-time model when she saw the casting
call and decided to try out after a
suggestion from her agent
angus cloud wasn't working as a model
but euphoria
was his first acting gig
jacob allordy's character is no stranger
to confrontation but
behind the scenes jacob ended up paying
the price for one of his fights
when nate fought with his dad jacob
admits the filming process was
physically grueling he wanted to make
things as real as possible
but maybe he got a little bit too real
jacob ended up with a concussion and
found himself throwing up after leaving
the set but
jacob managed to keep this injury from
sam levinson who was surprised to learn
about it after the fact
he clarified that there are medics stunt
coordinators and stunt doubles on set to
keep the star safe
roo's sister gia will be returning for
season 2 and according to storm reed
we'll end up seeing much more of her
this time around the first season
focused on a specific
character in each episode and storm says
it's time for gia to have her own time
to shine
she says we can look forward to seeing
her character step out of her sister's
shadow and step up as her own person
daniela davey is the head euphoria
makeup artist and she loves the fact
that sam levinson has embraced bold
bright colorful looks on the cast
apparently sam likes watching youtube
makeup tutorials as much as we do and
agreed to let her go all out
daniela claims that usually tv makeup is
designed to be consistent and
subtle but this is not the case she
tries to keep their looks consistent
with their personalities which is why
jules has such fun
imperfect and experimental looks at
first they considered having roo wear no
makeup but decided to
challenge people's perceptions of the
character by having her go bold and
sparkly when she does decide to get
dolled up
this is the first time that we really
get to see roo like genuinely happy
about life
it's clear that creator sam levinson is
all for pushing the envelope and he has
some strong ideas about where the series
is heading but a big reason the show is
so successful is because he's not afraid
to take input from the talented people
around him
according to hunter shafer sam admits
that there's only so much
a white straight man can know about the
diverse characters in euphoria
so he relies on the actors bringing
their own lives and experiences into the
script writing process
hunter says that it's a collaborative
effort and she believes that's reflected
in the nuanced characters
one area where sam does have a lot of
first-hand knowledge
he admits that in the past he struggled
with issues similar to ruse
complete with anxiety and mood swings
heightened by the teenage experience
even though there's a lot of careful
costuming going on behind the scenes of
euphoria
there are certainly plenty of scandalous
ones actor eric dane offered to bear it
all during a particularly intense scene
but the crew decided that it would be
best if he wore
a particular prosthetic part during a
scene when kat has a scandalous skype
call
she wanted to have a fake piece to look
at that way her surprised and scandalous
reaction would be completely genuine
according to barbie ferreira what we saw
on euphoria was her real reaction
and not an act
before he was cast as nate jacobs things
were not going well for jacob allordy
according to this euphoria star he was
practically homeless when he auditioned
for the show
he was completely broke when he showed
up for the casting call
and promptly forgot his lines despite
his mix-up and lack of acting experience
the casting director took a chance on
him and jacob couldn't be more grateful
working on the show has been a challenge
and there's one aspect of filming he
really struggles with
being mean to his co-star alexa demi
apparently
the two of them became close during
filming and even though he was just
acting
it wasn't easy to treat his good friend
so badly
some euphoria scenes take a ton of time
and planning to pull off
but the fight between rue and her mom
was almost completely improvised
zendaya and nika king were given just a
simple line in the script that said rue
and her mom have a fight and they were
forced to wing it from there in real
life
zendaya is a very calm person who rarely
raises her voice so this scene was a
huge challenge
this intense mother-daughter moment left
zendaya feeling light-headed and
nauseous
i was um with my mom and my uh
my little sister and we were listening
to this
this song are you looking forward to the
second season of euphoria
share your thoughts on your favorite
characters and predictions for what will
happen to them next with us
and your fellow fans in the comments
section stay connected with us here at
the things by clicking subscribe and
turning on your notifications
we'll see you next time